asalam alikum greetings of peace my next
guest a senior Jewish rabbi of over 30
years and I have a very important
question to ask him we're seeing many
Clips like this coming out of
[Music]
[Applause]
Jerusalem
and the mainstream media is not talking
about this anti-Semitism that's actually
happening down there we want to go ahead
and take a look at this clip so you can
see what I'm talking
about
he's also had a message to Donald Trump
regarding Jerusalem we will move the
American Embassy to the Eternal capital
of the Jewish people Jerusalem no no
he's one of the leading rabbis with a
movement now that's out there it's a
huge move ment you can see over 15,000
Jewish rabbis teachers and Scholars and
did you know that Jews and Muslims live
in peace for over a thousand that's
right A Thousand Years don't take it
from me take it from my next guest Rabbi
Shapiro I love
you was ready to talk about it I would
only talk to I was explaining how much
respect I have for the
how you doing Eddie it's great to be on
your show again it's good to have you
back how are you been how's everything
everything's been good unfortunately I
wish we could meet under better
circumstances with what's going on over
there in the Middle East it's it's
horrific can you help us make sense of
this we often we're hearing now rise of
anti-Semitism but now you have this is
it correct you correct me if I'm wrong
can we label this this in Jerusalem
anti-Semitism that the media is not
reporting out at all you don't really
hear much talk about this I get a lot of
these clips from on on X and you'll see
Torah true Torah Jews or this and they
post a lot of this stuff and you'll see
a lot of this uh happening can you help
us make sense of it there are a lot of
different types of anti-Semitism there
was the anti-Semitism of the Christians
in the Middle Ages that told the Jews
you either have to convert or we'll kill
you which means they had their
anti-Semitism was against the Jewish
religion and if you practice
Christianity they're okay with you then
there's the anti-Semitism of Hitler that
said it doesn't matter if you practice
Christianity the Jewish blood that you
have and it was his definition of Jewish
blood we're going to kill you anyway the
zionists are also anti-semites but
they're anti-semites
against the anti-zionist Jewish religion
they don't like the Jewish religion at
all unless you're a Zionist religious
Jew uh let me explain Judaism like Islam
like Christianity has many different
people that claim the exclusive mantle
of authenticity so by the with the
Christians you have the Catholics and
the Protestants for example you have the
evangelicals uh who don't follow the
pope it's completely different
denominations um in the Muslims you have
the C Sunni and the Shia and other
religions have that too in Judaism you
have Zionism and you have Judaism
Zionism is according to Judaism idol
worship it's that simple I can explain
to you if you like uh in detail how that
works but the the reason why they
created Zionism is as a substitute for
Judaism a modern political nationalistic
replacement and rebranding
re-engineering of the traditional
religious
spiritual identity of Jews that was
Judaism and any Jew that uh resists the
Zionist transformation of Zionism the
ones in the video that you saw are the
epitome of those Jews um the zionists
don't like they're anti-semitic against
the these particular types of Jews what
you saw that Israeli policeman doing to
that Jew is not the worst thing that
they've done no not at all I I practice
I practice martial arts so he did a he
did a a judo throw I mean he did a judo
throw that he could have killed I mean
he could have just um smashed the guy's
head on the wall he could have been dead
I mean why and he and he did it real
sneaky came up to him and unexpectedly
just SL you know th threw him down with
the Judo throw and then right on the
concrete we do it on mats he did it on
the concrete well well well thank god
the guy didn't crack his skull other
times they did Google pinus segalov who
was involved in the s he was a Jew who
was involved in a a peaceful protest
against Zionism they beat him to death
and um then when they came to court the
head of the Israeli police the chief he
told the judge these Nur guys means
these anti Zionist Jews they only
understand one language the heavy hand
so yes the zionists don't like the
Orthodox Jews unless you're of the
Zionist Orthodox Jews denomination which
is more Zionist than Jew or a
combination of
both why why do you think we don't hear
this I see this being talked about in
the mainstream media because the
Orthodox Jews don't own any mainstream
media nor do we have any influence over
it very little influence over it um I'll
tell you a story I once did a a radio
show uh broadcast over
WABC um it's a very large radio station
in New York one of the large
and it was on a Sunday afternoon where
they didn't have anybody they didn't
have any show somebody canceled or
something and some guys paid money to
have me broadcast and I did um we wanted
to do it again and WABC said no way no
way you make our no way it's much too
they get much too pre much too much
pressure against them for me to do it so
they don't they don't have they won't
let us um they there pressure that's
what it is and when we do make a protest
or something like that they're not
interested mhm you know there's a lot of
influence over the press and it's not
influenced by us I I learned a lot last
time we spoke U you unpackaged a lot and
people can go watch the program that we
did and it had to I had to revisit uh
because sometimes when you're doing an
interview then later it kind of sinks in
and you you covered some very important
points I just want to touch upon some of
those for our audience here uh the first
thing I want to start with is the
founder here you you spoke about Theodor
Herzel you spoke about beneran and you
said that they were not they were
not um practicing Jews they weren't Jews
they were actually atheists and then I
went to look look much of this up and
you had so many people also this is a
fact this is not fiction and many of
them were against Orthodox J Judaism is
that correct hey benorian said that
Orthodox Juda ISM meaning the Judaism
that says that a Jewish tradition
doesn't change is Nazi ideology that's
how he refers to our ideology uh
Theodore Herzel was you know the old
joke they say a Jewish joke what's the
difference between Theodore Herzel and
Jesus the answer is Jesus celebrated
kanah and Herzel celebrated
Christmas he was he he preferred
Christianity to Judaism he really didn't
like Jews especially anti-zionist Jews
he said that they are A different race
than regular Jews M there was an essay
he wrote It's called Mall m a u h l
maybe there's a c between the S and the
H um mall is an old anti-semitic word
for Jew kind of like [__] and um he said
basically that the anti-zionist Jews
that's what they are they're not real
Jews they the whole idea of Zionism was
to transform Judaism from spiritual to
political from religious to
International and to create a new
identity for the Jews because they
didn't like the old
identity uh my opposition to Zionism the
Jewish opposition to Zionism just to be
clear is independent of the issue with
Israel and the Palestinians so for
example um if let's say the Israelis and
the Palestinians would come to a
two-state solution and both sides would
be happy let's assume even the
Palestinians get 95% of the land and
Israel's left with 5% in the negtive
desert and everybody's happy let's say
everybody's happy but Israel remains
Israel the same Israel that it is
today um the Israelis may be happy the
Palestinians may be happy I'm not happy
the Jews are not happy because even in
that scenario you still have a state
that refers to itself as the Jewish
State refers to itself as the state of
the Jews um professes an ideology that
is a direct attack on my religion my
religion says the definition of a Jew is
that God gave the Torah to people on
Mount Si those who received it became
Jews uh they say no we're the state of
all the Jews Jews is jewishness is a
nationality and we're the state of that
nationality and you you American Jews
you British Jews you Belgian Jews you
German Jews you are all our constituents
so if we get into a fight with somebody
let's say the Palestinians are out of
the picture we get into some economic
fight with China for example um we are
and the Chinese will be angry at Israel
we American Jews will be sitting here uh
subject to the ire of the enemies of
Israel we have no interest in being
involved in any of Israel's politics I'm
not Israeli I'm not Palestinian I have
nothing to do with Israel I say those
uh left-wing Jewish organizations let's
say
jvp um I think that they actually are
counterproductive to a mid east peace
process and I'll tell you why let me ask
you something Eddie who are the enemies
of the Palestinians the Israelis or the
Jews who are the the the ones who
whoever the the people who are who are
there who are pressing them who are
their land is it the Jews or the Israel
it's not the Jews exactly it's Palestine
versus Israel it's not the Jews if so if
that's true and and it is it's not the
Jews that are the enemies that are in a
war with the Palestinians of what
benefit is it for Palestinians to uh Pro
to show that there are Jews that are on
their
side they should be shown their Israelis
on their side the fact that they
consider it beneficial to their cause to
say even Jews are on our side
presupposes that the Jews are the
enemy but you said that Jews and Muslims
Muslims and Jews were living together
when I opened up the program we're
living together I said don't take it
from me take it from a rabbi of over 30
years Jewish rabbi scholar and academic
that Muslims and Jews have been living
together for over a thousand years in
peace in relative peace is that correct
the Jews had a much better time under
Islam than they did under Christianity
in Europe and to the point where when
the zionists wanted to take over uh the
holy land so the Jews living there the
pious Jews living there went to the
British and they even went to uh the uh
Arabs to say to Turks the Ottomans to
say we don't want the zionists here we'd
rather live under anybody we do not want
them there there was a man by the name
of Jacob danan who was the messenger of
the Jewish Community there to the
British he was a high-powered uh
academic he spoke many languages and he
was considered a prominent uh modern uh
professor in many circles and he was a
good spokesman for the Jews they the
zionists assassinated him they
assassinated him uh they admitted it the
guy by the name of a toomi was the
Assassin they found him in
after the war and he said sure he was
putting Zionism in danger um the Jews
and the
Muslims uh lived in relative peace there
were better times than others there was
the Jew there was the Golden Age you
know there were other times but there's
no question that the Jews had a better
time under the Muslims than they did
under the Christians much better in
Israel or when Palestine in those days
the uh when the men the Jewish men in
Jerusalem went to Sy synagogue the women
usually didn't because they stayed home
to watch their children which is also a
part of a service of God equal uh to
going to the synagogue we have the same
we have the same thing for Juma prayer
same thing with the woman staying they
they're not uh it's not obligation for
them to go but they get also the reward
being at home yes there you go except
for one day on yum Kipper the holiest
day of the year the women go to the
synagogue now somebody has to babysit
the children but
that we same thing that's the comment we
have Eid now Eid prayer where they
encouraged to come out on that day yes
so guess who there no Jewish teenage
girls there to or boys to to babysit the
kids guess who babysat the kids when yum
Kipper Muslims Arabs B Babys set the
Jewish kids in Jerusalem that's how it
was until Zionism came and it's not only
I who say it did you hear that clip from
on CNN from Queen R of Jordan I didn't
see what what was that clip oh you have
to see it you have to see it that's from
the queen of Jordan the queen of Jordan
Queen R of Jordan had a interview on CNN
I want to absolutely and
wholeheartedly um condemn
anti-Semitism and islamophobia it's it's
never okay it's never Justified to
attack somebody based on their political
beliefs but I also want to remind
everyone that Israel does not represent
all the Jewish people around the world
Israel is a state and it alone is
responsible for its own crimes uh Jewish
people around the world many of them are
appalled by what they're seeing and uh
you know like you said islamophobia is
the other side of the same disease and
we uh Muslims we have to be the first to
condemn uh anti-Semitism we have had a
long history of peaceful coexistence so
this is not about religion it is about
politics and what we've seen uh in
recent uh years is the charge of
anti-semitism being weaponized in order
to silence any criticism of Israel uh so
Defenders or supporters of Israel who
cannot defend Israel's actions or or
conduct they revert to they revert to
shutting the conversation down by
acquainting criticism Israel with
anti-Semitism let me be very very clear
being pro Palestinian is not being
anti-semitic being pro Palestinian does
not mean you're Pro Hamas or Pro
terrorism I think Israel deserves more
from its allies than just uh uh
unequivocal support I think it deserves
some uncomfortable truths because if you
are a real friend you support your
friend when they're right but you also
tell them when they've crossed the line
okay that was Queen Rana H she mentions
the fact that number one Israel doesn't
represent the Jews very important for
people to know uh Israel tries to
convince people that their actions
represent the Jews they don't um now a
Jew could be anti-israel he could could
be pro-israel he could be semi-
pro-israel he could have whatever
opinion he wants but what Israel does
has nothing to do with the Jews to me to
Jews Israel is the same as Ukraine there
are Jews living in Ukraine and there are
Jews living in Israel um but Ukraine's
actions don't represent the Jews and
Israel's actions don't represent the
Jews what Israel wants is for PE
zionists want for people to think that
when Israel does something that's the
act of all the Jews and that puts Jews
in danger and that's what queen queen ra
and I am very grateful to her for saying
this that was saying that don't hold
Jews responsible for anything Israel
does here's the thing you remember
during the covid so there were people in
Chinatown here in New York that got
beaten up because they were calling it
the Chinese virus that's what happened
they were calling the Chinese virus so
they were beating up Chinese people now
obviously nobody's allowed to beat up
Chinese people because of a Chinese
virus those people are CRI criminal
those are thugs no question about it but
there are low lives criminals and thugs
out there there are Bad actors in the
street but even if somebody's a bad
actor and he will beat up Chinese people
because of a Chinese virus he would
never beat up an Irish person because of
a Chinese virus that's insane even if
you're a criminal you wouldn't do that
so there are criminals out there who
will beat up Jews in the street
anti-Semitism is rising as is
islamophobia all over the world because
of what's going on between Israel and
Palestine that's wrong and it's not
merely because don't blame all
Palestinians in America for what
Palestine does that's true don't blame
all Israelis in America this is
worse blaming Jews for what Israel does
is like blaming Irish people in
Australia for BL for what Israel does
Jews and Israel are two different things
it's not merely that uh
like um they are italian-americans that
come to America and now they're
Americans and don't connect them with
Italy anymore no my family's from Poland
I have nothing to do with Israel the
idea that there's a connection between
Jews Judaism is a religion that's my
whole identity I'm an American by
nationality and I'm a I I practice a
religion that says God gave Moses the
law on Mount Si and I follow that law I
have nothing to do with any other
country in the world except the except
the United States in of America have
nothing to do with some country in the
Middle East nothing their their idea
that Jews are connected to Israel that's
the definition of Zionism Zionism says
that Israel is not the country of the
Israelis Israel is the country of the
Jews now nobody should beat up anybody
nobody should attack anybody
non-combatant nobody
However the fact that there are bad
people out there that will attack
non-combatant why why should they attack
me what do I have to do with this fight
if somebody came to me and said well
you're Ukrainian and I'm Russian and I'm
going to attack you because you're
Ukrainian and you support Ukraine what
do you think I'm going to tell them I'm
going to I'm not Ukrainian leave me
alone that doesn't mean you should
attack the real ukrainians that just
means you what do you want from me I'm
not involved in this I am not involved
in the the Israel Palestinian conflict I
have nothing to do with it I have
nothing to do with Israel nothing to do
with Palestine I can have an opinion
about it the I have an opinion on Russia
and Ukraine the same way I can have an
opinion on India and Kashmir or China
and the yuger Muslims but I have nothing
to do we have nothing to do with Israel
and I I want to say this Eddie that and
and therefore I I really believe it's
it's counterproductive for the
Palestinian cause for them to uh Trot
out Jews and say look here's a Jew and
even he believes
that the Palestinians are right the
reason that's counterproductive is
because of what I said before if the
Jews are not your enemy and Israel is
your enemy if the Jews are not who you
have a fight with but Israel is and you
agree with that and these Palestinians
agree with that what's the point of what
benefit is it to say look this American
Jew he's American Jew even he agrees
with us you want find Israelis that say
that that'll be for your cause but to
come and say well Jews are not we're not
in a fight with Jews we're in a fight
with Israel but there's a Jew in America
there's a Jew in England that agrees
with us look everybody even a Jew does
it's a it's a paradox it's paradoxical
it's contradictory and the zionists know
this and the zionists are happy when
they have these left-wing zionists that
come and they say well we're we're we're
against the occupation you know what if
you find Israelis that are against the
occupation that'll be very good for your
cause but if you find Jews that are
against the occupation from England or
from America that's no different no
better or worse for your cause than if
you find Catholics or or Protestants or
or Hindus from in America or England
that's that that that's on your on your
side you you also um you spoke about
just going back in history a little bit
a chief Rabbi that at that time when
Muslim and Jews living in peace and now
you had this push to create this um this
state and the Jewish rabbi sent a
messenger to the British saying you
cover this now that they don't want the
Zionist to rule and then this was Jacob
Dean and then he was actually
assassinated Jacob danan Jacob danan was
assassinated by the zionists a man by
the name of Romi what happened was that
he was about to go to the British to
send a message to the uh British that
the Jews in Palestine have no interest
in the Zionist taking over and creating
a Jewish State um so this this was not
just a murder or or manslaughter this
was an actual assassination
assassination they made sure there was
nobody in the street um at that time it
was premeditated it was uh a group of
people together conspired he came out of
a hospital in which there was a prayer
uh Quorum that just took place he was
coming out of the the prayer Quorum and
somebody asked him what time is it he he
looked at his watch and they shot him in
the chest a couple of times they later
of course denied it but then they
admitted it they admitted it later this
happened did this happen in uh in the UK
no this happened in Israel in Israel
this happened in Israel okay this
happened in Israel before Israel was
created in Palestine and in the holy
land this happened in Israel in
Jerusalem this happened wow this was a
political assassination in the Middle
East we we talked about herzo it's
borian confirmed they were atheists um
how about the the person now he's using
the Bible the new when we spoke you said
Thank God former prime minister my prime
minister now he's actually the Prime
Minister and he's actually quoting the
Bible he's quoting uh certain verses
calling certain people amalekites but
then I remember we spoke before he said
he's also an atheist he's a secular
Natan is nanyu is completely secular he
is a rule about Netanyahu whenever he is
involved he involves self in biblical
exegesis or stuff like that he's
pandering to the evangelicals ah the
Jews understand that he's a joke when he
speaks about the Bible and that he has
no idea what he's talking about
understand he's a joke you you guys
understand he's a joke now the scholars
the academics not not even Scholars an
eighth grade Yeshiva student knows that
he's a joke he knows less about the
Bible than than an elementary school kid
and he knows amalik which is what he
referred to that's a uh that's a
nationality which we don't know who they
are now they're not like one particular
country they're they're somewhere we
have no idea where we don't actually
kill anybody but the you saw the clip
what he was you saw the clip yes I saw
the
clip he's out of his mind he's out of
his mind and he's using sorry go no no
sorry go ahead no and he's using that
amalik uh referring to Israel's
political enemies as the mik is a
nationality nationality more it's like a
a um a people a people whose Souls whose
very existence is the epitome of evil
you know again there you can't point to
a country and say that's them this was a
ancient biblical uh people uh uh concept
that today you can't identify we don't
know who they are or where they are so
we don't go around killing people but
for and Netanyahu to go and say that the
Palestinians are amalik and that um the
the reason why they are mik this was the
implication is because Israel's enemies
be are our God's enemies are the Jewish
people's enemies they're Eternal enemies
it's like an anti-jew I guess you can
call amolik you know the Christians have
an
antichrist it's not exactly the same
thing but you can call amle uh by way of
analogy the anti-jew so because Israel's
in a war with these people they're the
anti-jew they're the epitome of evil
therefore they all have to be wiped out
no it's insane and he's pandering to the
evangelicals every sixth grade Yeshiva
kid knows that Netanyahu is what we call
in Hebrew and Amit an ignoramus an empty
vapid vacuous um human being that knows
nothing about the Jewish religion which
he doesn't accept he is totally secular
completely secular and it was a big
Scandal which it shouldn't have been
when they caught him on video some
people in Europe when he was eating non
koser food in a non koser restaurant but
that's what he does he doesn't respect
anything of the Jewish religion he
doesn't keep the Sabbath he he doesn't
do nothing he is I want to tell you as a
rabbi I want to tell you something
whoever is a good Jew and closer to us
are those that are closer to God God is
our father and our King and I'm sure the
same thing with the Muslims uh whoever
is closer to God is closer to us right a
loyal Jew means somebody who's loyal to
God just like a loyal Frenchman it means
somebody who's loyal to the French King
the Jews have a king and that's God
whoever is loyal to him is loyal whoever
is further from him is further from the
Jews and therefore listen to me a Muslim
who believes in God and between me and
you the Muslims believe in the same God
that the Jews do the necessary existence
the first cause
um the creator of the world the creator
of everything those words necessary
existence first
cause ibben rush or alag gazali I know
about these Muslim philosophers from
studying Judaism I never in my life
studied any of Muslim theology but I
know it from mes from kkash from the
Jewish books that quote them and um
law-abiding Muslim average law-abiding
Muslim that doesn't worship idols that
believes in God that um has a follows a
regular system of civil law doesn't have
to be the Jewish one a civil law and
fulfills the seven noahide laws which
according to Judaism all the world is
obligated to fulfill and the Muslims are
one step closer to that because they
worship the first cause that's they
believe in it is closer to God than a
Godless atheist like Theodore Herzel wow
tell tell me you mentioned um mades so
mades how would uh we look mman is one
of the greatest he's like um he's looked
at as like one of the greatest Pioneers
Scholars of Judaism that correct of his
time yes is it of his time is is it true
that he was the personal physician for
salahudin I've heard this is that yes
this is true in fact I want to tell you
a story I have a friend guy from my
neighborhood he went on vacation and he
went to Egypt he went to visit Egypt and
and um he asked he hired a driver to
drive him around and he asked if there
were any synagogues here now for some
reason the drivers in Egypt are required
when somebody asks for synagogues or
maybe this guy just got suspicious he
called the police because he was afraid
this guy was coming to bomb the
synagogue or something he was he had a
baseball cap on he didn't look
specifically like a Jew he didn't have a
beard they ran their passports through
whatever technology they have and they
found out that the man's wife the
woman's maiden name was mimon means that
she was a descendant direct descendant
of mes wow when they found out they gave
her a royal welcome they brought her to
some Muslim school where the girls came
out one by one and kissed her hand they
brought them to the mman synagogue and
took out the Torah and let them read
from it they thought that that was a a
thing it really isn't a thing but it
doesn't make a difference reading the
Torah of a synagogue isn't actually a
thing randomly but they they meant well
um and they they wanted to put them up
at a a expensive hotel and they brought
that Israel was their next stop on their
vacation they sent them to Israel on
like a private government plane because
they said M manes M manes is like uh I
don't a celebrity a superstar in
Egypt wow I mean this is like opposite I
have this one Professor he's very well
known I don't know if you heard of him
he keeps coming up in my thaine uh and
I'm seeing some of his messages God sad
Professor God sad have you ever heard of
from from Canada no the name is familiar
but I don't think I know anything about
it uh someone like him and then Ben we
spoke about Ben Shapiro last time uh let
me for people like this God sad who are
pushing this and he's someone I he's
pushing this division you know this uh
that Muslims intrinsically they hate
Jews and you're see it's not about the
land it's not about any of these things
he's like this is is he's trying to link
it to its a theological thing that
Muslims want to eradicate Jews and
whatnot so when you hear stuff like that
H what do what do you what do you have
to say here's what I have to say um
Muslims do not intrinsically hate Jews
you're a Muslim I'm a Jew I don't think
you intrinsically hate me Queen R this
is the for crying out loud this is the
queen of Jordan you heard what she said
okay yes she does she's not nobody's
gonna nobody's going to put pressure on
her to say something else this is the
queen of Jordan all right now the reason
why they say this is if you look okay
Israel has a Ministry of hasbara I'm
sure you've heard of it right it means
propaganda literally the word hbar in
Hebrew means explanation you probably
have a similar word in
Arabic um I'm guessing hasbara to think
to explain something like that Savar
something like that anyway so in
Israel's Frank L was once hired by
Israel to figure out what the best
Arguments for Israel are and what people
who are arguing for Israel should be
saying and he actually the the Israel
project tip tip put out a a manual you
can get it online words that work that's
what it's called and in there it says
one of the things it says is that you
should always what did they say m make
sure you understand the the argument is
about say you should say the argument is
about ideology and not politics his
words are terrorism not territory and
the reason is because if you talk about
Israel wanting territory people will not
approve of that but if you say Israel
fighting terrorism then people will
approve of that that those are his words
that's the slogan terrorism not
territory so the more it's an ideolog
IAL religious War the less like number
one the more likely it is for Israel to
get support but two the less likely it
is for anybody to suggest that it's
possible to make peace because Wars over
territory you can compromise you can
make peace right uh you could change an
enemy to a friend we Adam Bomb we adom
bombed Japan once upon a time not long
later we w enemies anymore one one day
United States was fighting with Russia
against Germany against Hitler the
biggest monster in like history of the
world not long thereafter we were allies
with Germany against Russia that's how
politics works right um but if it's a
religious War if it's intrinsic there's
no hope for peace no hope to live
together no hope to to reconcile no hope
for change the Muslims are
intrinsically evil intrinsically they
hate the Jews intrinsically there's
nothing you can do also it explains the
motive for the Muslims it doesn't the
issue over here therefore is not what
Israel did or does or or what Hamas did
or
does the issue is Muslims intrinsically
hate Jews right that's what they want
people to believe so that that's a
blatant lie and that's a that's a
blatant lie it's a blatant lie the issue
the issue is not Muslims the issue is
not Jews the war has nothing to do with
Muslims and Jews the issue has to do
with Israel and Palestine or now Israel
and Gaza that's where the war is it's
politics it's an issue of territory it's
an issue of two countries that has
nothing to do with Jews it has nothing
to do with Muslims besides which a lot
of the just like Netanyahu is secular a
lot of the Palestinians are secular
right Arafat was married to a Christian
right and there were there are plenty of
Christian Palestinians and there are
plenty of Palestinians who are secular
um this has nothing to do with religion
and nanyu trying to make it have to do
with religion he can't fool the Jews
he's pandering to the evangelicals it's
like uh so people can understand it's
like we have uh prayer five times a day
we have the Juma on Fridays so there are
certain five pillars of Islam that you
go ahead pray or fast ing charity all
these things if you're not doing it then
you're just Muslim by name a name tag
Muslim you're not so this kind of the
same thing what we have here tell me
this uh you made an equation to the the
idol worship and this is something that
is what we call shik shik is like the
the greatest sin that somebody's
associating partners with God Almighty
the Creator and you mentioned the story
of the c i I think you mentioned the C
it it started to have me think of the
calav when you had a certain group and I
want to link this back to when we talked
about someone like Ben Shapiro after we
have a concept called te if somebody is
doing certain things then the scholars
would talk with him question him and
then they can not just a layment to Tech
fear to excommunicate him take him out
of Islam uh but there are certain things
that if he does that can take you out of
Islam and that's one of the greatest
things if you're worshiping other than
God Almighty so would you say that it
had me thinking like with someone like
Ben Shapiro and the like because you had
certain group at that time Moses who he
love and rever is one of the mightiest
Messengers so he got the the Torah he
got the the Commandments from God when
he came back there was certain group
that were worshiping the Cal we have
this uh story there in the Quran they
came they're worshiping the Cav and can
you equate at that time people like Ben
Shapiro who were doing the idol worship
with at that time at this time people
like that who are trying to represent
Judaism Jews but they're actually like
those those those followers at that time
who did idol worship who weren't the
true how would you in what category
would you put someone like this Ben
Shapiro and people the like the people
who are pushing they're they're the
front actor the reason I mentioned him
because this is one of the strong
proponents actors who are really pushing
you know for war pushing for the
annihilation of certain people and
whatnot right so the the first thing as
you mentioned uh I forgot what the
Arabic word that you used before you
communicate anybody take take fear
before you go over to him and talk to
him or something yes it's the same thing
over here so judging an individual
person I would have to hear his side of
the story and if he but if he admits yes
he's a Zionist and he believes that
Israel is the state of the Jews and as a
Jew he needs to be loyal to a particular
country any element of nationalism yes
absolute idol worship and I will explain
why it's no different than if a person
bows down to a totem pole in Judaism and
here's why
the definition of a Jew
is better more accurate than calling it
a religion I would call it a job
description given by God to fulfill
these 613 Commandments and thousands of
subdivisions of
them um therefore if I say as a Jew I
must do XYZ what that means that's part
of my religious
practice if I say because being a Jew
means only a type of religious practice
practice the same way being a policeman
means that you have a job to be in the
police force and if you say as a
policeman I must do this you mean as
your job of being a policeman if I say
as a Jew because I'm a Jew therefore XYZ
that means it's part of my religious
practice so if I say as a Jew I have to
fulfill the Torah or as a Jew I have to
do XYZ because it's in the Torah or it
or or it's proper according to the Torah
then that's good but if I say as a Jew I
have to be loyal to a certain
country then I'm saying that's part of
my religion part of my Jewish identity
is
something physical political outside of
religion and that's no different than
saying as a Jew I have to bow down to
this Idol it you don't need to have to
say you don't need to say this Idol has
created the world or this Idol has power
what you do need to say is that uh a
this country or this totem po or
whatever it is bowing to it is part of
my religion part of my Jewish identity
we'll put it that way this part of my
Jewish identity besides the Torah that's
idol worship or if I say this country is
going to save me the Jews are not in
God's hands now we finally have a
country now we finally have an army
that's
called that you don't rely on God you're
relying
on an army an individual his fate he's
allowed to carry a gun if he feels he
needs to he's allowed to like I don't
know take uh karate lessons like you did
um he's allowed to lock his doors at
night because as an individual is an as
an individual because that he's not
doing it as a Jew but if you say the
Jewish people the Jewish people are
under God's control as a whole
collectively for somebody to say the
Jewish people as a whole now are better
off because Israel has an army or Israel
exists that's what we call cfir you have
a word for that I know in Arabic a kofer
yes KU to do KU yes okay so we have a
kafir same word to deny same thing yes
same thing yes it means denial and uh
aside from that aspect of it if a person
thinks that he as a Jew is connected to
anything as a Jew he's connected to
anything besides
God and the Torah that's idol worship
because you're bringing into your Jewish
identity which means your religion
something other than what belongs there
so how would you someone like Ben
Shapiro does he would you say he falls
under that category of idol worship If
he if he what if he believes any of the
above he absolutely is um there are Idol
worshippers like Benjamin Netanyahu who
substitute the Jewish religion for idol
worship uh there are those who in the
like in the days of the Bible who were
regular Orthodox Jews uh but worshiped
the
Bal uh there are Orthodox Jews who
worship idols too today and there are
there's a big temptation just as there
was in the olden days to worship idols
there's a different type of temptation
but there's a big Temptation for Zionism
today especially with all the propaganda
that's turned out tell me this so before
we conclude just have a couple more
questions if you can help me understand
because so from you mentioned Christian
Zionism and I know there was a person a
priest by the name of John Nelson Darby
and they had they he created this uh
dispensationalism are you familiar with
that absolutely this dispensationalism
and then you had all of these um what I
understood speaking to a Christian
Pastor these weird strange teachings of
Christianity and then you had a the
Cyrus scoffield who met someone who knew
John Nelson Darby and they put all this
in the scoffield Bible
they pushed this I think this got funded
from the American Zionist Association
maybe you can help me understand this
also from your perspective and they
pushed this out there million I'm just
giving a condensed version they pushed
this out there this is actually fake
teachings that are really not even part
of
Christianity um and they got they pushed
this into the churches they pushed this
uh into the um American public and what
happened is that we also have today we
have this this fake I call it this Force
prophecies that they're trying to
fulfill this Rapture and whatnot and
then you have the Third Temple Institute
and they're trying to rebuild the Third
Temple and can you help us understand
this from a Jewish perspective sure it
started earlier than those guys I'm
reading now from a website IJ usa.org
called that's the International
Christian Embassy in Jerusalem the
history of Christian Zionism in 1587 a
man named fr Francis KET was burned
alive for expressing his belief that the
Bible prophesies the return of the Jews
to their land moreover in
16007 Thomas Brightman published a book
in basil called the revelation of the
Revelation in this book he wrote or
whatever some bunch of Zionist Christian
Zionist stuff yeah late 1500s early
1600s this is before any Jewish Zionist
was born in fact there was a Reverend
William Heckler who came to Theodore
Herzel and introduced him to heads of
state he was a Christian Zionist he had
some kind of ideas that uh hurt Souls
that Zionism is the beginning of the
Redemption the Final Redemption where
Jesus comes back which by the way there
are many Zionist Orthodox Jews that
believe that the state of Israel is the
beginning of the Redemption our Messiah
the Christians had that idea way before
they did a lot of Zionism is taken from
Jewish Zion Zionism is taken from the
Christian version the Christians have
this idea that the Jews are uh going to
return to their homelands before the
second coming of their Messiah and then
there differences of opinion among them
some believe that when the Messiah comes
the Jews will be killed others say
they'll convert and there other opinions
but those are the two main lines um just
as I told you before that whoever's
closer to God is to me um closer to me
um is and and a Muslim who believes in
God is closer to God than an atheist
like Theodore Herzel and when I say
closer to me I mean uh you're not my
enemy those people people who don't
believe in my king they are further from
me um but to the zionists whoever
believes in Zionism is closer to them so
yesterday in Washington DC there was
this big um pro-israel rally there and
you would think that the speakers it was
organized by Jews guess who one of the
speakers were who Paul haggy yes yes I
saw that Paul ha was there yes so so you
have a a
anti-semitic Christian guy there were no
rabbis by the way who spoke the only Rel
the only uh you called him an anti so
have an anti-semitic guy yes anti but
but if the anti-semite is even if he's
Christian Jews don't believe in
Christianity any version of it right we
don't believe in it at
all um they God is a trinity not like
yours which is a first cause they are
further from Judaism in terms of
theology than
Islam they didn't have any rabbis
speaking you can you don't lose your
place you can actually as a the rabbi
you can pray in a Masid right a mosque
is that correct yes no yes I'll get back
to you in a moment with that the answer
is yes the the it's it's a there's a
disagreement amongst our authorities but
the bottom line is is yes um
the um this guy because he's a Zionist
he spoke at a Jewish event it was
organized by Jews they had Orthodox
Jewish zionists there he he's the
leading he's the he's the leading
leading one Evangelical for this uh
cause isn't he in America yes and he one
of them I don't know if he's the but
certainly one of them he was like the
there were no rabbis who
spoke this is Zionism Zionism is
replacement for no rabbis no Orthodox
Rabbi no no no none zero just just a
Christian Evangelical Tel Evangelical
whatever they call him and and don't
forget I think I saw some clips and some
some uh some music bands uh yeah I I
didn't see all of that music it it was
that Judaism is a connection between the
Jewish people and God yes we are
different religion than Islam no
question about it Islam is a different
religion and I know you Islam believes
in abreg we don't we consider it against
our religion no question about it it's a
different religion
but at least uh Muslims believe in in
the right God they're not Idol
worshippers like other religions and for
that that we were people of the book we
were considered to you guys all the time
right yes absolutely
but
the atheists are much further from My
Religion than Muslims are atheists are
further they don't believe in any God
even an idol worshipper is closer to me
theologically than an atheist now to
zionists whoever is closer to loyal to
Israel that's what counts Kurt Oran he
could be an anti-semite it doesn't
matter nanyu coddles up to him you can
have a guy like hegi it doesn't matter
if he's Christian what his beliefs are
Zionist boom he speaks for them now as
far as the M the Masjid is concerned I
have to tell you interesting thing that
the word Masjid Orthodox Jews should
know what it
means uh in our prayers we have a state
I was thinking thinking somebody told me
this I didn't even realize this a friend
of mine we have a a statement in our
prayers it's in
aric means we are Servants of God we bow
to him sagid means we bow now the
sagid if you use the soft gimmel like
Egyptian it's
Sid and whenever you put an M sound in
front of a word like that it becomes a
place so maid in our Rabin Aramaic would
mean a place where you bow am I correct
yes prostration M prostration that's
exactly what it means and the Earth God
Almighty Allah is telling us the whole
earth is made as a place of sjah as long
as there's certain requirements has to
be clean and whatnot but Saga
prostrating to only one and only one God
so sagid is our word for bow for
prostration
s oh s s s that's right s yes it's the
same word it's the same word um but you
know
again Theodore Herzel theoretically
could have repented and then he would
become a good Jew like me and in terms
of potential he has that potential but
so long as he chooses not to repent and
remain an atheist and all atheists they
are further from my theology than
anybody that believes in any God
certainly people who believe in the
first cause necessary existence the Sia
Risha uh the creator of the
world uh your message to Trump you had a
message to Trump can you uh before we uh
conclude uh we have a few minutes left
uh what was that message about because
he was mentioning Jerusalem capital and
you made a specific message uh to to
Trump on
this Zionism transforms Judaism from a
religion to politics from spiritual to
political capitals of places are a
political entity it's a it's the most
important city in a state or in a
country Jews are not a state or a
country Jews have no Capital even in the
days of King David when Jerusalem will
call it the capital of King David's uh
Kingdom if there was a non-jew living in
King David's Kingdom Jerusalem was was
his Capital also the capital is a
capital of a place the Jews are a
religious community it makes no sense to
say the Jews have a capital Trump said
Israel is the Eternal excuse me
Jerusalem is the Eternal capital of the
Jewish people he is conflating more than
conflating
substituting Israel for the Jews and
that's precisely what Zionism does
Israel becomes the religion Israel
becomes the focus of identity Israel
becomes the center of Jewish life and
and jewishness itself and that is an
attack on my religion a much bigger
attack than uh saying that okay I don't
believe in a particular part of uh a
particular detail this is a fundamental
attack on our je our
religion have you ever visited uh
Bosnia bosia no no think my son did yeah
I think so there's also a big uh well
small but um to this day a Jewish
Community there that um uh found a place
of Home in Bosnia you had Albania you
had um places like this and uh there was
something I read regarding the Jewish
community in Bosnia so I thought I think
you like it there if you ever visit
visit Europe let me know I can have
someone show you around sure thanks a
lot that's where my family's from from
really Bosnia yes from I may take you up
on that yes please so what do I tell
people when I say I usually mention you
I mentioned Rabbi Weiss I mentioned Pico
pillet I mentioned people like this I
consider you guys my friend you know
we're not like close close friends like
we hang out all the time but uh but we
have the potential to be I would i' love
to have dinner lunch with you but when I
when I see you guys who are really
practicing Jews you practice Judaism
usually when I hear some of these guys
like Ben Shapiro and others can is it
safe to say Can I I call them fake Jews
I call what do I call them like I
usually you call them misguided Jews
call them Idol worshipping Jews you can
call themist Jews and that's that there
was a rabbi in a a seminary that the
kids in the school were arguing whether
you know what to how to refer to Zionism
with fake or or Idol whatever so the
rabbi said what do you mean the worst
thing the most anti-jewish thing you can
call them is Zionism you don't need
anything else oh wow yeah Zionist Jew
and again this has nothing to do with
politics this has nothing to do with the
war between Israel and the Palestinians
again even if the Palestinians were
happy and they had everything they
wanted I would still have the exact same
objections to
Zionism Zion it's very clear if anyone
can take anything away Zionism is not
Judaism absolutely either listen to me
or queen ra we both agree on that me and
the queen of Jordan uh what what message
also for people uh young Jewish people
out there you know coming up and you see
all the programming conditioning how can
they get more educated on this is is
this a common teaching now like in more
so in the Orthodox uh schools here in
America with the with the youth coming
up and what advice do you have for them
who are confused and they they they want
to go on the side of the Thousand Years
of true peace that Muslims and Jews had
and we want to we want to revive
this here's what I was first read my
book the empty wagon zionism's Journey
from Identity Crisis identity theft the
empty wagon empty wagon they can read
empty wagon yeah and secondly if you
want to learn about your Jewish identity
don't go on Birthright trips don't don't
subject yourself to Israeli propaganda
to Zionist propaganda you want to learn
about your Jewish identity and your
jewishness go to an orthodox Rabbi not a
Zionist Rabbi go to a regular Orthodox
Rabbi that studies the Torah and read
Jewish books there are all sorts of uh
books on our religion there are all
sorts of people that will help you
understand what Judaism is don't subject
yourself to some political uh
nationalist fake uh Judaism they're just
using their name in order to attract you
as a Jew to their ideology claiming that
they represent Judaism they represent
Judaism no more than I don't know the
black Hebrews represent Judaism or or
supersessionist Christianity represents
Judaism Zionism is just another
supersessionist movement you want to
know about Judaism in fact send me an
email go to my websites go to my go to
rabis Shapiro Donnet I have links to
everything there and any Jew who's
interested in uh learning more about
Judaism rabish Shapiro Donnet I will
hook you up with with somebody that can
help you out what can I say as a as an
ending term of endearment respect uh I
would say I don't want to you know God
bless you may Allah bless you like I
know something about not saying a
certain
name or you said the how Allah is fine I
have friends Orthodox Jews from Syria
leppo Damascus and they call God Allah
that's another misconception right there
it's a whole different topic so you have
Jews also who are from this area who
speak Arabic and they call on the
Creator by the name Allah sure they say
inshah they say inshah yeah sure so may
may Allah bless you thank you and same
to you thank you my friend thank you
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you're not yet Muslim and you tune in
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go ahead and visit theen show.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with
youum I'm Dr Awad and I'm so excited to
be here at the dean Center Mah which is
under renovation and I can't wait to see
what's going to come inah there's going
to be a daa center there's a Masjid
there's a school an Islamic school a gym
and what we hope inshah will also have a
mental health part of this Center as
well inshallah so I'm asking you to
please make sure that you support this
effort inshallah I really hope that it
spreads and really the knowledge of
Islam and people get to know more about
Muslims and Islam through this
[Music]
effort